thank you zoe
um so the purpose of this session is
simply to uh we've spent the last two
days engaged i think in in pretty
fruitful conversation and so um i don't
know was it dan you that suggested this
someone on the program committee
suggested that um rather than having a
final session we have a final session
where we get a moment to sort of sit and
reflect and collect what are the themes
what are the major takeaways that we
or areas for future work together or
research that we would like to see move
forward past this workshop
so we've collected some themes from the
various sessions and from the twitter
stream
and so i'll be happy to share those but
i'm just curious
from the group
what were the
major insights
questions
areas for future work
that you are taking forward or would
like to share with the group
we have the mics caring around
so dan garcia uc berkeley i was very
pleased with all the talks and all the
connections we made i really appreciated
the 15-minute presentation 45-minute
discussion those were just wonderful and
sometimes it's half and half and i
appreciate the time to connect um what i
would love to see is some more of the
social learning
that we use in our classes used here
embedding that so i we what we've done
with our pd with high school teachers is
at the beginning of a pd session might
be a week-long pd session we have a
shared google doc and every person gets
the url in minute one and we all can
contribute to that so as i present
something i say someone says hey try
this url and i throw the url up on the
screen rather than everyone's trying to
copy what i'm doing someone pays into
the shared doc we all have it instantly
so been really nice to have kind of have
pre-set up shared docs for each of the
sessions so that as people are shouting
out urls one person pastes it it's done
we all get it and just kind of that
lives on beyond it um i also uh in in
the sessions we ran with our high school
teachers um we always for every slide
deck we ever showed we had the top first
slide um welcome to the slide here's the
title and here's the url to download
these slides today because i think i saw
a lot of us including myself were typing
a lot of the slides in fact especially
this morning i would have loved to have
had that
with me with slide numbers even so a lot
of times the presenters didn't have
slide numbers so a slides in advance b
slide numbers and c a group shared
document i think those three things
could have set this on fire so that
would be useful for the future thank you
so that's a that's a great uh learning
or takeaway for how to organize the next
conference i'm interested in those but
i'm also interested in uh
content
of the things that you learned or themes
that came
to you that you're interested in taking
away
get just enough
um so i had uh two insights one is i was
just so incredibly grateful and and
continue to be uh amazed by the
practitioners who are so deeply invested
in connecting with research so i'm
incredibly grateful for course
developers from harvardx from lots of
other schools you know who are under
incredible pressure just to ship courses
um and still are think you know keeping
so much in the focus of what they're
doing how important it is to be
taking insights from research and be
contributing to insights and research
and i think their contribution to this
work is fabulous and i think including
them
you know making sure that there's that
there's constant dialogue between the
people who actually are building these
things day in and day out and
researchers who have a little bit more
remove i think is incredibly important
and a great feature of the conference
and as it played out was important to
many of the discussions um that we had
and then i would say another theme that
sort of emerged for me was that there
are a lot of people just in the same
place and are running across a lot of
institutional challenges and the more
mechanisms that we can develop to share
the way that we're getting past those
challenges so for instance like as
happens at a lot of these kinds of
workshops you know the the irb came up
was a pretty constant theme and like
somebody out there just needs to like
get a hundred irb protocols that have
been accepted and like put them in the
same place and let them all read them
and tag them so we can copy them from
each other and share and share with our
ib boards and things like that we were
talking a little bit just yesterday
eric klopfer and some folks here
launched a publication called education
express which is meant to be a journal
and a website that publishes not just
sort of fully formed articles but more
methodological notes other kinds of
things along the way we were thinking is
there is there a venue there that we
could publish something about some parts
of this process or someone taking that
on but i think that was a big theme for
me was sort of thinking like what are
some of the as we find ourselves in
these moments in building a field where
there are common challenges that we're
encountering
how can we share the solutions of those
challenges in efficient ways so that we
all are not you know reinventing uh you
know 100 different wheels in 100
different places
great so two things the intersection of
practitioners and researchers
co-creating and informing each other's
work that was a big takeaway for you and
then also fight and recognizing that
we're all at very similar places in uh
dealing with institutional issues around
being able to conduct research so
looking for a community or a place to
share what's working ways that we're
working around with irbs and other
things
yeah
carolyn do you wanna
is there a microphone down here
oh you got one over here already go
ahead
go ahead and go next yeah
from mit and university of tokyo
i just want to echo what the previous
speaker said it's been a terrific
conference uh just one for the
the positive energy that's flowing
through stata is
it's palpable i i do want to make one
suggestion based on my own experience
from having worked with open courseware
uh which started here at mit and when we
wanted to expand it out we were
initially a uh a u.s centric
uh
sort of group uh but very quickly we
expanded uh globally and that gave that
that group uh dynamism that really made
open courseware uh
even more exciting
and uh the one thing that i do feel
about this uh
uh conference as i've already told some
people is it is somewhat u.s centric and
uh i think that uh it would be great you
know there's so much that's going on in
asia where i spend half of my time as
director of online education at the
university of tokyo
so much in south america uh and we love
to hear about africa and of course
europe and so there it would be great
uh next time if you could expand your
horizon you know through your steering
committees and program committees to uh
to become global as moocs have become
global that's great so um the big
learning is that we are going to
to expand our horizons to look at more
global
uh perspectives on this so one
suggestion might be this is the first of
this conference let's do it again next
year in asia or in south america
uh i i was told i have the next place in
the mic queue
uh armando fox from berkeley uh this has
been a great time i wish there hadn't
been quite so many parallel sessions
because there was always something i
couldn't go to because i was going to
something else that seemed equally
interesting at least at the time um but
i think one thing that i've taken away
from the discussions
i thought i was just going to get away
with that
the one thing i did take away from many
discussions
uh i've spoken to a bunch of people who
are education learning sciences people
primarily uh cognitive psychologists
primarily computer scientists primarily
like myself
obviously duh this is an
interdisciplinary research area and
there has been a lot of criticism that
moocs version 0.9 which i feel is kind
of where we are now
reflects almost none of what's come out
of the learning sciences research in the
last few decades and by the i think i'm
one of the few people who's not ashamed
to say you're right
computer scientists have this habit of
doing things we do a lot of engineering
to get a breakthrough in along a
dimension such as scale or affordability
or something you know if you told
somebody 15 years ago who was doing
online education that in 15 years there
will be a worldwide free to the end user
content distribution network for video
with automatic captioning by speech
recognition and automatic translation of
those captions you would have been left
out of the room but that happened so
what computer scientists do i think our
view of the world especially the systems
world is we try to push the barriers to
sort of get to a new plateau that was
not imaginable 215 years ago and yes
many of us are naive about the kind of
research that really ought to inform the
platform that's going to be delivering
we hope learning materials and education
we want to learn that research and we
want to meet you halfway and we have to
learn to speak each other's languages so
you know i have been inhaling as much of
literature as i can um you know having
contacts like candace and her team at
stanford and my own colleagues at
berkeley is very helpful but i'm
encouraging both sides to reach across
the aisle here yes we are ignorant of
much of the education literature maybe
more than we should be on the other hand
you know i've been teaching for 15 years
and i never got any literature handed to
me on the way in the door on how to
teach in the classroom either so we want
to meet you halfway and the more for i
would love to see a talk 10 papers that
every everyone who stands in front of
students should read practical results
from the educational learners that you
can apply in your classroom tomorrow
i've been writing a blog post to that
effect over the last three months and
someday i'll finish it but this is i
want these kinds of events to be
reaching across the aisle events and if
computer scientists can educate
educators about why we do what we do and
educators can educate us about what
works and what doesn't i you know i'm
sure we can do something great here so
i'll come to the next one great
so i actually think that that is
something that we did i i'd be
interested in hearing feedback but that
was something we were trying to create
the space for here is as you put it
crossing the aisle that's kind of an
interesting
metaphor for that um and i think that
that at least the conversations i was
seeing because i kind of know who's in
which camps if you want to think that
way and there seemed to be a lot of that
inter that cross-disciplinary uh
conversation which is much better than a
year ago great yeah yeah
yeah
okay
so
i'm ursula walls and i've been giving
different stories to different people
about my background but
i am a die-hard in the classroom
collaborative
use technology for individual learning
but it's the pure communication that's
essential kind of person and i spent a
year with linstein at olin so i'm even
more corrupted
um i'm first of all grateful that you
let me in because my application was a
rant
and the reason was a rant was
three years ago i did a um
a keynote where i was supposed to
introduce faculty in education to what
is it that computer science do
scientists do
and before i got up the provost at the
institution got up and said well okay so
we have this conference on educational
technology but these moocs are coming
and they're about to replace you
what are you going to do about it he
addressed the audience of of of college
educators and i went up there and said
i'm in deep trouble
what i'm grateful for here is the way
the dialogue went from mooc
and disruption which is all that the new
york times talks about with moocs to
blended and community and online
community and face-to-face community and
not looking at
how can we show that moocs are better
but rather how can we show that moocs
can be integrated into the personal
relationships that happen in classrooms
so thank you so much for that i've come
out as as
um an acolyte i'm i'm excited about
where this is all going and for all of
you let me play with you
thank you so yes this notion i think
that we did celebrate here which is
we're not looking at
moocs as replacement
for higher education but really looking
at how do we use the technology
effectively to augment and
uh how do we use what we do in class how
do we use we do faculty how do we use
what we do with peers and how do we
combine those different resources to
create the most effective learning
experience for our learners
carolyn you've been waiting a long time
yeah so i guess um my question might be
it's uh strongly related to armando's
question maybe from from the other side
um i'm proud to say i'm a researcher and
i came to this this workshop with the
idea of this is my opportunity to get my
work out there and have practitioners
hear it and now i'm realizing oh that
was a really um
arrogant way of thinking about it and
i'm just remembering that there's been
this issue with a lot of um learning
sciences conferences a discussion about
trying to involve practitioners and
policy people and the feedback we always
get it seems is
you know i can't make heads or tails out
of your research um what are we supposed
to do because good research raises new
questions you know keeps things
ambiguous you know we have to keep
ourselves in business you know but also
it's just it's complicated and usually
we don't have the simple answer and
usually we can't you know oftentimes um
somebody wants like well what are the
what do you really know well not a lot
for sure you know and so i guess my
question is so it sounds very positive
this idea of the kind of exchange that
happened at this workshop but what i'm
wondering from the side of people who
came here as practitioners not as
researchers when they heard the research
presentations were they left with that
feeling because i haven't heard people
complain about that but i wonder if
there's some of that sentiment out there
um
that's not being expressed or if
everyone is close enough to a researcher
that they just expect the ambiguity and
so then it was less of an issue this
point so that's a question you're asking
that's the question i'm asking
particularly to practitioners that are
not uh directly researchers so anyway i
was next in the mic queue but i can
answer that question because i'm a
practitioner and i'm not a researcher
and i really enjoyed being exposed to
the research that i heard about at the
conference i didn't think i had a
particularly hard time ingesting some of
it um what i'm worried about though is
uh my ability to to use it right to sort
of operationalize it and and it's not
because i don't want to right because
there's like you know half a dozen
things that i've heard about that i
really like to try my own course uh i
think i have the problem that other
people who are not affiliated with the
edx's and you know you know armando's
center and other other places have who
are out there hey no leave them like
alone
you already had your state um
so you know so the people who aren't you
know i'm often in sort of outer space
right i mean i don't have you know a
studio on campus that i can go to to
record videos right i don't have a team
of people that are helping me design my
class right i still want to use some of
these resources i'm capable of doing it
right but but what i really could use
and as
as like everyone who tells the nsf what
to do
i expect to receive some of this money
but i think that it would be great if
there was funding for practitioners to
put some of these ideas out in the field
right not just in the context of sort of
edx and other types of really well
organized efforts by elite institutions
right they really have the money to do
this themselves if they want to right
people like me who you know my time is
valuable and i have other things to do i
would love to try this right but i need
a little bit of space at my institution
so that i can have an excuse to actually
work on teaching right and take some of
the steps necessary to experiment with
these things right so so again i would i
would love if there was like an nsf
maybe there is right a program in the
education area that was kind of like
operationalizing existing ideas in the
field of education right
so
sorry i said armando wants to say
something and
yes
we're both systems guys yeah in our area
what the name for what you just
described is software yeah i think that
they're reaching across the aisle
challenge the the artifact
version of it is how many of the best
practices from the education literature
that is are successfully adaptable in
this context or maybe can even be
improved in this context can be packaged
into software so that people who do not
necessarily know that research still
benefit from them yeah like a really
simple one right i didn't realize that
someone has done a meta-analysis of 80
years worth of multiple choice questions
to figure out how many options you
should have in a multiple choice
question
it's three
and i can point you yes and i can point
you at the paper that is unbelievably
well written so
this is a simple machine checkable thing
right i i can have software that
embodies known best practices helping me
when i put together my core so even if i
don't have a team of researchers and
educators around me
i will avoid at least doing some wrong
things so i think that the way that i
would pose the interdisciplinary
research challenges it's not just what
research findings can be come up with
together it's how can we package them in
a way that people who aren't familiar
with the findings will still be able to
benefit from them at least indirectly
that's for me that's the real
opportunity of mooc software and your
advocacy is to build them into the
authoring tools as much as possible
recognizing that there's a number of
interesting avenues of research where
there isn't
any set way to do that but i think
there's probably a lot of low-hanging
fruit that we could do
and you know those are just a matter of
let's learn how to talk to each other
and figure out which of those we can
start immediately putting into practice
because i agree with the criticisms that
most moocs and platforms today pretty
much are not buying us any of that
okay other respondents uh to carolyn's
question other practitioners
i'm just interested in hearing from yeah
so i'm not a practitioner but i i
one of the things that i found
a lack of in in a lot of the discussion
here is that it was really very much
focused on traditional notions of higher
education
and so one thing that moocs do have a
lot of that i didn't really see here
from a practitioner point of view was
things like the udemy's or
the
code academy or the things that are
really about skill
teaching etc and it may be that these
things are just
you know learning is learning and and
however you use it but um i i didn't see
much of that it was something that i
thought might be an interesting thing
for us to explore the future
so
one other interesting thing is there's a
lot of questions about learning
technology how it's implementing
practitioners but also there are huge
problems practitioners are facing so for
example
when you're doing things like proofs how
do you automatically grade proofs so
there are these kind of unsolved
problems so it might be interesting for
have a lot more practitioners also
talking about their unsolved problems
and the learning community can think
about that and say okay look there might
be better ways to get that information
across than what you're trying to do
today so in some sense i think there's a
lot from learning community to bring
practitioners because what practitioners
are looking is is to use use that
information but also
i think there are a lot of unsolved
problems that learning community can
help guide it into a place where you can
actually find a technical solution that
will have a better efficacy than that
banging their head on on on certain
paths so i think it might be good to
have
more practitioners here talking about
their hard problems i didn't see that
much saying okay look i am running into
really hard issue by doing this i am
trying to do natural language processing
analysis of
open text and here are the issues i am
running into grading those things and
and i think if you look at that if you
look at because
in even computer science there are easy
problems and there are hard problems
and there are certain hard problems that
will never be solved but if you can
redefine the problem and make it easier
then you will have a lot more impact on
practitioners you can say look you don't
have to solve that problem because just
solving that problem won't give you that
much bang for the buck how about if you
make the problem different so i think
you can have that impact but for that
you need to understand the learning
community to understand where the
computer sciences are hitting the wall
and i think having them talking about
where the heat in the world could be
very useful and i think i think there'll
be a lot more collaborative effort that
you can do with that yeah i think that's
a really great point smart i mean i
think that it's a question of when we're
trying to get people to collaborate
finding a shared and meaningful goal
that makes all parties
see the collaboration worthwhile of
working together and that could be i
mean i could think of it i mean i'm
thinking of like three different parties
that we want to bring together at least
the the computer scientists the
technology people the disciplinary
faculty the faculty who are trying to
just teach chemistry or poetry and then
the learning researchers and and the
impetus to work together could come from
any of those three areas it could be
start with a faculty member saying
why don't my students get equilibrium
i have explained it
14 different ways why don't they get it
and a learning researcher could say oh
well let's let's unpack what's going on
conceptually around that and maybe we
can help solve that problem and we can
design an intervention that both solves
your problem but also allows me to make
progress on my particular theory of
complex cognition
and similarly i mean so i think that we
need to look for forming in some ways i
think we need kind of a clearinghouse
for how these different
people can find each other to
collaborate to find a shared problem
that they can work together on solving
right can we solve my problem but can we
and i guess there's the question of can
we frame your problem
in a way that not only solves your
problem
but also solves a greater more basics i
mean it's i don't know if people are
familiar with this idea of work in past
years quadrant sort of if we're trying
to solve a real world problem like in
edison's quadrant um
what if we just work on solving that
problem then we'll solve that problem
but we won't learn anything from that
that contributes to our fundamental
understanding or if we're just trying to
do basic science research up in bohr's
quadrant then we might come up with some
good basic science knowledge that in the
long term has some impact someplace but
it's really hard to know how you apply
that it's like the issue you were
bringing up carolyn how you apply that
research to a real world problem so the
key is is to structure your
interventions your research up in past
years quadrant where you're both trying
to solve a real world problem
and also trying to make progress on a
fundamental understanding
of say learning science and
i've dreamed of trying to find some way
of bringing together practitioners with
researchers with software engineers to
identify where are some of those shared
problems that we can make traction in
both directions together
so other themes
so uh i i'm going to address all of them
and answer none of them but um to from
the practitioner point of view and i
guess from the platform point of view
the big takeaway for me was uh richard's
point this morning about teams because
um you know we've worked very closely
with
sarah and xiaolin and the group at kent
kenji's group at the graduate school and
and from litik's lab as well and they
their experiences practicing on our
platform have led to different
technological solutions and updates
right and so that's just something that
because we're all co-located we're
working on a very real world problem
there were all these students in there
we had to fix some stuff but that was
just an accident because we were all
there working together and i think if we
can intentionally
bring people together more in these
teams it would help because i don't you
know when something's breaking in the
software at 11 o'clock at night i don't
have time to go read a paper if i can
find it and then i probably won't
understand it right and then how am i
going to make a recommendation on the
engineering board for this is the
solution to fix it by 6 a.m right so but
if but if we're all working on these
things together then we can come up with
a more positive solution for the
learners and i think that's what i took
away from this and so thank you for that
so i thought i would just throw in a
suggestion about what's in the nexus of
those areas and i think it's data right
i mean i think that's what you know
software engineers are will be happy to
produce right people like me will be
happy to generate through our
instruction and researchers can consume
and use right so i think
you know the the idea that
it seemed to me through this hearing
people's about their struggles working
with data from certain mooc providers
that maybe there's a little bit too much
of that that's sort of trapped in
various places right um one thing that
that another community that i'm involved
with did that was very effective one
year as as part of a workshop like this
was that they actually organized it
around a competition to analyze data
sets that were donated to the workshop
by in this case it was iran to cellular
provider but maybe edx wants to do that
or coursera or one of these platforms
wants to just give us a big dump of data
and sort of some of the papers and some
of the data analysis or the discussions
in the workshop can be organized around
that right as a way of getting some of
that data out there yeah that's great
carolyn you're doing something like that
aren't you
yeah
so great suggestion and taking immediate
action on it
so i i took the microphone back um as a
point of information for those of you
who are really committed to to
interdisciplinary work and your
description of it where there's this
this common
abstraction that that everybody
contributes to is essential um lillian
castle at villanova and i were given a
eager grant i guess four years ago now
i've kind of lost track to look at the
the climate for interdisciplinary
computing
and we brought together over the course
of two years i think close to 120
researchers and and practitioners
in a whole variety of fields both within
within the sciences and engineering but
also we had journalists and artists and
poets and and
a few teachers and a few educators in
there too but you know that was my
insistence um and and that was there
were two things that were key in that
work one was to make sure that all of
the stakeholders and within the
collaboration
had a meaningful
role in it that it wasn't just the
software developer implementing
something that somebody wanted but that
there was this real balance of
contributing knowledge
and the other one which still saddens me
um and is a major reason why i'm not an
academic anymore is that the political
atmosphere the professional
advancement atmosphere for researchers
especially
is not conducive to that kind of
interdisciplinary work and i am
heartened because
um
nsf had a a job posting a couple of
months ago looking for somebody who
could specifically do that kind of
cross-cultural work between disciplines
so
if you all can find a way to create
models for that with the
resources that you have um within
within building moocs
um
go for it
please go for it but you know bear in
mind the professional development how to
how do the practitioners get credit for
this within their institution how do
they find it how do the researchers
write the papers they need to write in
order to be credible um you know how do
the software engineers solve the
problems in a meaningful way so that
everybody is happy
i wanted to comment on armando's idea
and how we could take or should take as
much as possible the things we learn and
bake it into the platforms and i think
we totally should but then there's other
things that you probably cannot very
effectively at least put into the
platforms but should be at the
practitioners hands those who are
building the courses and there's a bunch
of people as here but then those who
aren't quite focused enough on these
questions to come here but if we had an
easy resource for them that we could
package the results that would be very
receptive so that's one of the things
that i would think that
of all the wonderful things we heard
here working together maybe as a part of
the workshop next time what can we give
a one pager three ideas that if you do
these things your course will be better
and i would imagine that there would be
a lot of things we could do for people
who would have even less time than the
practitioners here to really comb
through the literature
anyone
hi i'm jen i'm from cal arts um
and i actually i've really enjoyed this
conference it's been a very enlightening
experience listening to my colleagues
speak about other courses that they've
developed
but i do feel like the gentleman in the
middle of the
auditorium here
who mentioned we were missing the
conversation about skill-based courses i
felt like stem seemed to be the primary
focus or primary theme at the conference
and of course
art space moocs are on
the horizon and it would be great i am
if you are
an instructor or an administrator or
someone who's planning an art space mooc
or running an arts based mooc or
thinking about running an art space mooc
i am trying to find you so please
connect with me
um
but yeah just that i feel that uh
many of the platforms that are currently
available to
any uh arts based institution
does primarily cater to stem-based
courses
and um although we seem to be co-opting
those resources for our own use we would
be able to or would be ideal to see
um some other opportunities to create
create a space for students to take a
risk or fail rather than trying to
master a subject so i would like to see
those types of conversations happening
in the future as we move forward and
innovate moocs
okay
so
anybody else want to share an insight
okay then whimmy would i'll oh there's
somebody great well i was just gonna
respond um there are our art space moocs
and uh you might look at penn state did
uh my colleagues there did an art
course that was
um
absolute joy for the instructor and the
students alike um and seemed like an
incredibly
cool model that you might might explore
it was offered through coursera
yeah but i think i think your point is
well taken though too
it would be really interesting to get
together specifically arts faculty
with the learning researchers with the
software engineers to start off saying
what's the learning experience we're
trying to create and how do we
shape the technology to better fit those
particular learning goals
which is a different frame
so
yeah i think it's a great idea
anything else
okay oh yeah go ahead
yeah i was just gonna um show uh what
the themes were that some of the other
themes that came up that uh didn't
necessarily get mentioned here well then
i'll just throw it out quickly okay
hi i'm joseph williams from stanford and
moving to harvardx one thing i was
curious to throw out was
would it help if
we structure discussions and also
practical development and research
around two things
one is components or modules and moocs
um more like instead of thinking of a
whole course could we think of mooclets
or some components like videos or
exercises
and the other also is experiments um
rcts a b tests
and so the motivation for this is based
on what i'm seeing people do like in the
office odl at mit they'll get modularity
um i think dr vargo was looking at um
how you could actually facilitate
collaboration and then david pritchard
is testing experiments many other people
are but the reason i throw it out is
that it seems really hard to have um
clear discussions and clear practical
implications without focusing a more
fine grain level than entire course so
if we were to think from a practical
perspective
how do i motivate learners to solve more
exercises or problems i can then
actually frame this almost like a
thought experiment or
maybe a thought randomized controlled
trial
if i change this exercise by adding this
message or if i gave learners more
explanation what the exercise was for
what measure or what assessment would i
expect that to affect and so just what
i've observed and looking the way oli
does research three main things in terms
of a b tests a versus b versus c and how
does it affect something else d
that seems to be a really valuable
scientific methodology but it also seems
to be a natural way that we can express
our differences in opinions well i think
this would happen so this this kind of
manipulation of this kind of design is
going to help people stay in the course
longer also make them do better on this
assessment and that might be a nice way
to kind of get people focused when
they're collaborative they can design
experimental conditions together and put
up modules better and when they're
competitive you can frame your decision
instead of as a argument but actually
testing it out and that also has a lot
of implications for where software
development would be focused
so just kind of throwing it out thinking
about experiments in mooclets
okay so it's a couple themes that came
up um so the way we organized the themes
were just to pick out a couple overall
themes and then the and then these are
specific tweets that uh
that were in those themes so a couple
main themes were
i mean these are people brought up
now that we have a richer understanding
of the technologies to support massive
open online courses we should focus our
attention on understanding how best to
support learners in this environment
and then our goal and this will make
barbara happy is barbara
barber here still no
uh our goal is should be a fully open
cycle open content open platform open
data open models for analyzing the data
and then there's some tweets
there's no l in mooc but there should be
do you remember that that was from i
guess that was a that was quoting
someone
yeah
and then uh richard clark saying teams
are the solution to designing tech based
instruction for higher ed and i think
that point was made several times here
already
then there were some specific themes
that came up in the area the main themes
of the conference were design
teaching research and technology so we
kind of organize the themes and those so
better design occurs when there's a team
i mean this whole team idea kept coming
up over and over again but specifically
teams of content experts instructional
designers measurement and assessment
experts
and then this point i think was also
made already that we have decades of
research and how do we incorporate that
into
our current
designs
and there are a couple tweets
there might be lots of great content but
it's not necessarily designed for
particular audiences i think this came
up in the you need to have a
design from the beginning the audiences
that you're targeting and then i
actually like this quote from susan
unless we address the assessment
question
from the get-go we might as well just
all go home
and then in teaching
this acknowledgement that asking
teachers to
completely change their practice is
is a big ask um
and so they need support and scaffolding
for changing that practice
and then some questions about how do we
rapidly change instructional strategies
and then sort of the acknowledgement
that came up here i think from armando's
statement too that you can be have a phd
but that doesn't necessarily mean you
know
how to do education
a subject matter expert
that's uh education jargon
and then
i won't read these because it's actually
bad powerpoint practice to read exactly
what's on the slide
i could i should actually put a url at
the top so that you could have
downloaded these and made notes on them
and that bottom tweet is kind of related
to the question of how should the
research research be driven
that currently it's being driven a lot
by what data do we have so what kind of
question are we going to ask as opposed
to what we usually do in research which
is what question am i trying to answer
and so what data do i need
and then the last area is technology
it's interesting there weren't as many
themes in the technology area as there
were in the teaching and research area
but that tweet it's not the technology
but what you do with it it's kind of i
think the summary for the whole
conference
okay
thank you
so one thing we have been trying to do
is capture
all the information as possible in on
with the website so uh we are going to
put that large uh twitter feed so we put
that on the website uh all the sessions
were recorded and it takes some time to
put get them out so by tomorrow you'll
have every session a video on the
website and also we are going to collect
everybody's
presentation and i think ross has a
google doc to collect those uh google
drive and collect them and we'll put
them in the website so we will try to
make it a resource that going forward
you guys can use to watch uh give it to
students and tweet
so hopefully
this we can keep it as a useful resource
for a while
one question i have is from quick hits
we collected lot of interesting material
however there's a little bit of a
privacy concern because a lot of people
we have emails pictures and stuff like
that so we decided not to put that on
the website uh perhaps we should all
we should email it to the all the
participants uh like a pdf and if you
don't want your quick hits included or
if you want something to be omitted just
send a mail to
me or us and and we will do that and
hopefully the next couple of days we
will send it out
thank you
you